what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to pop culture explained
and one division
is not what you think it is as an avid
comic book reader and somebody who's
been reading mobile comics for 25 years
i would like to say that i've pretty
much seen it all but one division did
initially throw me for a loop but i
believe that i know exactly what's going
on here now there are all kinds of fan
theories right there's all kinds of fan
theories
going on out there on what's taking
place on who's involved all that kind of
stuff and a lot of people are pointing
to the idea that it might be mephisto or
cathone who are basically the ones
using wanda maximoff and doing all this
crazy stuff i don't think that's
actually true but for the sake of
explanation who are these guys and why
do they matter so much okay
so starting with cathone this guy his
name is spelled c-h-t-h-o-n he's what we
call
an elder god meaning in the early days
of earth earth was not originally
inhabited by humans instead it was
inhabited by these just super powerful
demonic entities who were all ultimately
destroyed it was weird you basically had
like this thing called the demi urge
which killed all the all the elder gods
or most of them those who didn't escape
and then merge with the sun
it's some crazy stuff for marvel comics
but for all intents and purposes cathode
was one of these elder gods and he was
wildly powerful he had the ability to
channel something called
chaos magic which was just this insanely
powerful form of magic but what ended up
happening is after he was defeated and
he was banished to his own realm he's
always tried to find ways back to earth
and the most viable way of doing that
was to use scarlet witch as an avatar in
the sense that when she was born
catholic reached out and touched her and
imbued her with a fraction of his power
under the idea that at some future point
in time he would be able to seize
control of her and then use her to bring
his own essence into the world and then
basically conquer earth all over again
now the reality of this is that if the
throne ever showed up on earth in marvel
comics with full power
nobody would be able to stop him right
he'd just be this insanely unstoppable
being and everybody would lose and die
right that's just
kind of how that is but during the
events of house of m scarlet witch used
the full totality of the power that was
available to her presumably
all the power that she could use that
belonged to catholic and she rewrote
reality on a universal level right
change the entirety of the universe it
was kind of crazy the way this went down
she essentially took the mind of charles
xavier she read it and then
subconsciously learned or learned the
subconscious desires of everybody on
earth and then recreated reality to give
everybody
everything they ever wanted so magneto
for example was the leader of the mutant
race which was the ruling class of the
world at the time
all kinds of stuff like that but of
course once the actions of scarlet witch
were revealed
she was confronted by doctor strange and
the avengers and so on and so forth and
then
basically set everything back to normal
but said no more mutants and 98 of the
mutant population lost their powers
there's a lot more to the story than
that you can find
the story uh you can find a link to it
down in the description it's on my
comics explained channel i cover the
whole thing in its entirety but that's
that's one of the things that people are
pointing out right the cathode is kind
of the guy behind this uh that little
house of m segment will be important
later on but one of the other things
here
is mephisto now mephisto is what we call
a demon lord or
a hell lord in marvel comics the way
that hell works in marvel it's not
really depicted the way it's done
in judeo-christianity for example where
it's ruled by like one guy
and it's just a place of suffering it's
not really that way instead in marvel
comics
hell is kind of like this giant
geographical place we can call it the
united states and that if each one of
these states was governed by a hell lord
that's what hella marvel comics would be
so say for example
that like texas is ruled by mephisto
then that's how it would work in the
realm of hell and marvel comics mephisto
just rules one
segment but the way this guy works is
say for example that we looked at the
events of avengers end game and if you
guys recall that exchange where scarlet
witch confronts thanos and then says you
took
everything from me if she had
immediately followed that statement with
and i would do anything to get it back
then if we were reading that in marvel
comics
everything would stop right all time
would just stop and everybody would
freeze where they are and then mephista
would just appear probably like a snake
or just mephisto in his proper form or
he might show up in the form of vision
whatever form he can take that would be
most conducive to getting wanda to
accept his his offer and his offer would
come in the form of what would you be
willing to do to get back everything
that you previously lost you know what
would
you be willing to sacrifice right would
you do anything would you make a deal
with the devil in order to make it
happen and she would probably say yes
nanny would say okay cool deal's done
here's vision and she would bring vision
back but he would he wouldn't have any
of his character traits right it's just
kind of the way that mephisto screws
with people right so like he'll bring
back the person you want most but then
like three days later they'll die of a
brain aneurysm or something along those
lines right he's just a really
he's just a dick is really all he is but
that's how mephisto would work right he
would bring back vision but vision would
not have
any of his personality traits he would
just be this android that existed out
there that didn't
really have any personality whatsoever
but the other thing that that happens
with mephisto is that once you end up
making a deal with him when the time
comes where you die he gets your soul
right so he basically takes your soul
back to his own realm
in the plane of health i don't think any
of that is what's going on in one
division i don't think any of that is
what's happening here
one of the first things i think we need
to understand here is that wanda
made things this way and both she and
vision know this the other thing to
understand here is that scarlet witch's
powers as she's using them now most
likely resembles something like the
jasper's war right for those of you guys
who don't know what that is
the jasper's warp is a concept for
marvel comics whereby
mad jim jaspers has started distorting
reality within his localized space on
earth but it started spreading outward
it created this cascading effect that
started to spread throughout the
universe and they actually had to
obliterate his universe to keep it from
spreading into the multiverse so he was
viewed as something like a cancer or a
tumor
now this is a really important thing to
understand because of a story that
marvel wrote not too long ago called
phoenix resurrection and phoenix
resurrection was a story that basically
dealt with the return of jean grey but
it wasn't as though jean grey as the
phoenix had just popped up all of a
sudden
instead what happened is the x-men
started picking up on these weird little
uh energy signatures from around the
world and then ultimately traced them to
a place where the energy signature
seemed to stop and coalesce and what
they found was this small little town
where jean grey had basically recreated
her life the way she wanted it to be but
this is an important thing because if we
take
all this stuff that we've talked about
here we wrap all of this around and we
look at the different clues that we've
seen just over the course of the first
two episodes
this all points to the idea that
nothing's what we think it is i think
what's really happening here
in wanda vision is that in the aftermath
of avengers infinity war right so wanda
basically experiencing a psychotic break
with the death of vision having had the
death of her brother take place in age
of ultron having the death of her
parents happen when she was younger
literally being surrounded by death and
loss
so frequently she just snapped and by
whatever manner and whatever means which
we don't really know
she basically just created this perfect
world for herself and so what this means
is that when you look at somebody like
dottie that dottie is
may very well just be a person who was
there right just a person who was in
this town that wanda just
chose perhaps and that she was living
her life and doing her own thing
and all the various people that we see
there are all basically playing roles
that wanda has
imposed on them it's why if you look at
that situation where the voice comes on
the radio right jimmy wu comes on the
radio and he says wanda who did this to
you
that dotty's saying things like i don't
believe you right when wanda says like
look you know we're just we're here to
just you know enjoy our lives and and we
don't want to we don't mean anybody any
harm or anything like that
like dottie says i don't believe you and
she becomes like really cruel really
mean really fast and then then seems to
kind of snap
out of it like who are you what are you
doing here and then the radio kind of
crackles and then the voice goes away
and then suddenly daddy goes back to
where she was before
i think that is marvel taught or the
marvel cinematic universe tying in the
idea of wanda maximoff's kids right that
when agatha harkness was a babysitter
for wanda maximoff in the second volume
of vision and scarlet witch and she was
babysitting their kids she realized that
whenever wanda maximoff's concentration
was broken her kids would disappear and
that's when she realized her kids were
not actually kids they were just
constructs that wanda had created that's
what it looks like it was in that
situation when the voice came on the
radio
and distracted her the illusion started
to fade even if only for a moment and
that's why dottie snapped back to her
normal self like who the hell are you
like what's going on here and then as
soon as scarlet witch regained control
then basically dottie went back to being
the person that she was before now this
also begs the question
why do we see characters like geraldine
why do we see characters like agatha
harkness who's basically agnes in the
one division tv show i think they're
there
because they're trying to either find
some way to snap wanda out of what she's
going through
or because they're spies to keep an eye
on what's going on to see what's
happening and to basically report back
to sword
this is where things get a little murky
here because sword in in the marvel
cinematic universe as we see it here
is not sword as we traditionally know it
sword basically stands for
sentient weapon observation and response
department and we could largely assume
that sword came in the aftermath of like
the first avengers movie or even going
back further than that when we saw the
avengers film and nick fury was talking
about how they developed all these
tools and weapons and things like that
and when the question was asked why he
pointed the finger to thor and he said
because thor revealed to them that
humanity was not alone in the universe
right that there was other life out
there and sword
i'm sorry shield had to be prepared for
it and so that's when they began
preparing for the development of sword
we don't really know yet right we don't
have
all the all the answers in terms of how
sword came into existence but if that's
truly the case then it makes sense
right because geraldine is basically
monica rambo right she's the little girl
that you saw in captain marvel who would
eventually grow up to become the
superhero spectrum that has the ability
to manipulate the entirety of
every form of energy that exists out
there now whether she actually will in
the mcu i don't really know but again at
this point
we're all really just guessing we don't
have any definitive answers here but if
i'm a betting man
i think that's exactly what's going on
that everything we're seeing in wanda
vision
in in terms of her like making stuff
appear and disappear that's all really
happening she's altering reality she's
learning about her powers
as she uses them she's doing things that
she's never done before and the result
is that it's changing things
across the entirety of the universe that
is having this cascade wave that could
spread possibly into the multiverse
setting the stage for doctor strange too
basically it's a one movie that's a
giant giant cleanup job
but that's what i think is happening
right i think this is all just wanda
maximoff's doing i think this is all her
like she's totally aware of what she's
doing she's not oblivious to it she
knows what's happening and if there is a
bad guy in this story
it's her she's the one that's basically
doing things and and i guess
you know the the bad guy s concept will
come in the form of her eventually
losing control of her making so many
changes that she can't undo them right
the single biggest thing that points to
this is her
rewinding time after the beekeeper came
out of the sewer she just says
no and like rewinds everything and then
the beekeeper never came out of the
sewer she's
actively keeping sword out of this world
she's created
because she doesn't want anybody to make
any adjustments to it now of course the
last thing this asks us here is
why does wanda vision look the way that
it does right why do we have wanda
vision existing in the form of like some
old black and white tv shows that were
basically modeled after i love lucy and
the dick van dyke show
i think a lot of that is because those
are the shows that wanda maximoff grew
up on when she was a little kid
and she was living in sokovia and she
was watching shows those are the kind of
shows that she was watching and so it
makes perfect sense that if she's gone
through all this struggle and all this
strife and she wants the quote-unquote
perfect life for herself she would model
her life after what she saw as being the
perfect life which is
what she saw on tv so it makes sense
that that kind of stuff would happen all
right this is kind of what's going on
but you know let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section i'm
curious what your opinions are
and uh yeah if you guys are new here to
pop culture explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob poor if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you